yeah
and starting now book TV on c-span 2 is
live from Chicago this is the home of
the printers roll it fest it's currently
in its 32nd year and it's sponsored by
the Chicago Tribune many local and
national authors you'll hear from today
and tomorrow today some of the authors
include OJ Simpson trial prosecutor
Marcia Clark he's written a new novel
the co-author of the Broadway musical
and book Hamilton the Revolution you'll
also hear from Seymour Hersh his most
recent book is the killing of Osama bin
Laden which takes a critical look at the
foreign policy of the Obama
administration and much more so for a
complete schedule go to our website look
tv.org you can see the full schedule of
our coverage there you can also get
scheduled and behind-the-scenes updates
on our facebook page at facebook.com
slash book TV or follow us on twitter at
book TV we're going to kick off our live
coverage of the printers roll it fest
today with thomas frank his most recent
book is called listen liberal or
whatever happened to the party of the
people this is live coverage on book TV
on c-span too
good morning everyone 32nd annual
Chicago Tribune printers roll it Fest my
name is Thomas Collis and I'd like to
give a special thank you to all of the
festival sponsors the theme for this
year's festival is what's your story and
we encourage you to share the stories
you hear this weekend on twitter
instagram or facebook using the hashtag
PRL f/16 you can keep the spirit of lit
fest going all year by downloading the
printer's row app where you'll find all
the Chicago Tribune is premium books
contents free and discounted ebooks for
subscribers and the complete printers
roll it fest schedule download today and
you get a free ebook and five dollars
off printers roll it Fest merchandise
today's program is being broadcast live
on c-span to's book TV we're going to
leave about ten minutes at the end for a
Q&A session with the live audience here
so when the time comes if you have a
question please line up at the
microphone to your right so that the
home viewing audience can hear the
questions and lastly before we begin
this program I ask that you silence your
phones and turn off the flashes on any
cameras with that being said I'd like to
introduce author Thomas Frank
of listen liberal
howdy folks how are y'all doing that's
my my that's my version of the Chicago
accent howdy folks I did live here for
many years
down the Southside down in Hyde Park and
I know all sorts of like really useless
facts about the city did you know for
example that William Jennings Bryan gave
the cross of gold speech about like
three blocks from where we're sitting
right now yeah so what you talk about in
a political history man this is the
place so like I say I lived here for
many years and in fact when I was living
here I wrote a book Oh 12 years ago
called what's the matter with Kansas and
about yeah oh yeah okay awesome
well it was a book about all the
different ways that the Republican Party
roped in working-class people with all
these different varieties of fake
populism you know that the Republican
Party is so incredibly skilled at
inventing and today as we look around us
I mean basically we're watching before
our eyes the rise of the greatest fake
populist of all times Donald Trump right
who even this guy is like Huey Long
without the compassion you know I'm
saying that as we watch this I want as
we watch this happen I want to talk
about something that I wrote about in
the Kansas book but that I didn't really
go into in detail back in those days and
it's just this that a large helping of
the blame for the right-wing backlash
that I saw back then that we all see
today that a large helping of the blame
for this thing has to go to Democrats as
well the degree to which Republicans
have won these working-class voters over
is the same degree to which the
Democrats have abandoned them okay and
so I think that this is the year to ask
whatever happened to the party of the
people I mean this and it's a great
question to be asking just a few blocks
from where William Jennings Bryan
basically launched them on their modern
career is our
party of the left but I mean this
question in two ways first of all how is
it that the Democrats came to abandon
working people right the great middle
class of this country and in a related
point
how have the demirtaþ that the democrats
have basically failed to respond to the
greatest issue of our times now what do
i what do I mean when I say that what
failure am i referring to well President
Obama has said and I agree with him that
another Chicagoan by the way I'm going
to every time I every time I check of
Chicago and I'm going to point it out
I met Obama once we'll talk about that
later on I lived in his neighborhood he
was my state senator down in the south
side but we'll talk about that later
right now I'm talking about Obama's
ideas and what he's done as president
and he said that a couple years ago that
inequality was the defining challenge of
our time and I think he was right about
that the defining challenge of our time
it's a sweeping statement but when you
think about it for more than just a few
seconds you realize that it isn't
anywhere near sweeping enough okay
inequality I don't like this word it
seems far too technical but it's you
know it's what we got so I'm going to
use it inequality is a kind of shorthand
for all the things that have gone to
make the lives of the rich so much more
delicious year-on-year for three decades
and also it's shorthand for all the
things that have gone to make the lives
of working people in this country so
wretched and so precarious inequality is
visible in the ever rising cost of
health care and college in the
coronation of Wall Street and the slow
blighting of wherever it is that you
happen to live you catch a glimpse of
inequality every time you hear about
somebody that had to declare bankruptcy
when one of their kids got sick or when
you read about the lobbying industry
that drives Washington DC or you hear
about the requirement that all of our
political candidates must either be
billionaires favorites or actual
billionaires them
Elves inequality is about the way that
speculators and even criminals got a
helping hand from Uncle Sam while the
Vietnam vet down the street from you
loses his house inequality is the reason
that some people find such incredible
significance such incredible meaning in
the ceiling height of an entrance foyer
or the Hopf content of a beer while
other people will never believe in
anything again inequality is a euphemism
for the Apalachee fication of our world
and i know i mean me of all people i
know that it's the republicans who bear
the primary responsibility for this
modern plutocracy that we live in they
are the party that launched this country
on our modern era of tax cutting and
wage suppressing and these are the guys
that made a religion out of the market
and who fought so ferociously to open
our politics to money at every level I
know all that but just blaming the
Republicans one more time turning the
old TV set back to MSNBC folks this is
not good enough not anymore because the
things I am describing represent a
failure of the Democratic Party as well
look protecting the great middle class
order used to be the you know what the
Democrats were all about this was that
party's traditional mission and once
upon a time their leaders would have
taken one look at the situation we're in
today and they would have known exactly
what to do now I'm not trying to lionize
old-school Democrats right they had a
lot of things wrong with them as we all
know but you take a guy like Harry
Truman or Lyndon Johnson and they would
have they would have known precisely
what to do about this current economic
situation that we're in right these guys
were screwed up in all sorts of ways but
one thing they were really really really
good at doing was defending the middle
class this was right shared prosperity
was the Democratic Party's in the old
days their greatest
their highest aim defending our
middle-class world was a sacred task for
these guys and they would frankly they
would never shut up about it they talked
about it all the time and to this day
some bits of that some vestiges of that
still remain if Democrats are the ones
who are always pledging to raise the
minimum wage and the taxes of the rich
but when it comes to tackling what
President Obama calls the defining
challenge of our time
however many of our modern Democratic
leaders falter they acknowledge that
inequality is this terrible thing is
awful thing and they know that it's out
of control
but they can't find the conviction or
the imagination to do what is necessary
to reverse it so instead they offer the
same you know high-minded policy
platitudes that they have been dishing
up since the 1980s they remind us they
say there's nothing anybody can do about
technology or globalization right
globalization right that's that's the
hand of God reaching down to rearrange
human affairs nothing anybody can do
about that
and so they promise us you know what
they promises charter schools job
training right student loans right
they'll shovel out the student loans but
other than that they got they got
nothing folks let's take the let's start
with some specific issues the main one
and you know this what's the main issue
of our century of our dumb little
century here the Wall Street bailouts in
2008 and 2009 this was the great missed
opportunity
this was the historical inflection point
where our country could easily have
changed course but our leaders chose not
to remember what it was like back then
President Barack Obama had been elected
on this massive wave of hope and
enthusiasm on Election Day 2008 there
was remember the amazing party just a
few blocks from here in Grant Park you
know thousands and thousands of people
elected on this amazing wave the
country's at his back the wind is be is
out of everything
all the forces of history are behind him
and he proceeded to continue the
policies of President Bush essentially
unchanged but I'm referring to his
policies towards Wall Street towards
into the investment banks no big banks
were ever put into receivership no
bailouts were unwound no elite bankers
were ever prosecuted Obama and his
Democrats refused to change course when
every sign was telling him to turn when
it would have been good policy to turn
when it would have been overwhelmingly
popular to turn when the country fully
expected them to turn and when I say the
country I mean the bankers themselves
the Wall Street bankers thought that
they were going to be taken to the
woodshed and when it was fully within
the president's and his party's power to
steer this country in a different
direction they didn't do it now what I'm
saying is that on this matter there was
no conflict between pragmatism and
idealism and this is a conflict that
we've been hearing a lot about during
the primary season right the pragmatic
candidate the idealistic candidate right
but on this issue what to do about Wall
Street there was no conflict the
idealistic thing was also the practical
thing and the healthful thing it would
have been good for the economy and the
popular thing the public wanted him to
do it they were behind him but enormous
numbers and he chose not to now I know
that the Democrats are the good guys for
a liberal like me the Democrats are the
good guys or rather I should say the
less bad guys but when you start with
something like that this Wall Street
issue the way I've been describing it
it's not a coincidence that all the
economic gains of the recovery that have
happened since then presided over by a
Democratic president a president that we
were often told is the most liberal of
all possible presidents if not an
outright communist right that it gains
all the economic gains of this recovery
that he has presided over have gone to
the already wealthy and this is not I
should say not only because you know
sinister diabolical Republicans keep
supporting the righteous liberal will I
Republicans are awful and I know how
they play the game I live in DC these
days they're very good at it
they're they are dedicated to
obstructionism it's like a philosophy
for these guys but what I'm talking
about here is something different it is
a straight up democratic failure Obama
played this issue the way he did because
that's how he wanted to play it we have
to get our heads around that now I call
this a failure but you know what the
right word for it is this is a betrayal
and the history of this betrayal goes
back a long way
when I was a young in the 70s in the 80s
the Democratic Party you know you'd read
the newspaper the Democratic Party was
forever grappling with its identity you
know arguing with one another over who
they were and what the Democratic Party
stood for and this went on for decades
all through the 70s all through the 80s
up into the 90s all of these different
factions within the Democratic Party
basically fighting like cats and dogs
you know but what's funny is that they
all agreed on one thing all of these
different factions agreed on one thing
and that was what that what the
Democrats had to do was turn away from
the legacy of the New Deal with its
fixation on working-class people that's
what they had to do so the man who
brought this up you know closure let's
say to this long-running democratic
civil war was of course President Bill
Clinton and I think if we want to
understand where the Democratic Party
and the country are today this is one of
the turning points that we have to look
back at and we have to scrutinize in
some detail a Bill Clinton brought a new
kind of Democratic administration to
Washington rather than paying homage to
the politics of Franklin Roosevelt which
is you know what Democrats used to
always do right he was the patron saint
all that sort of thing
Quentin did the opposite he did these
kind of singular favors for FDR's old
enemies for the banks the radio networks
the power companies basically the boss
is he deregulated Wall Street he insured
it when I say he deregulated Wall Street
it wasn't just one or two measures it
was throughout his presidency
you know item after item after item
after item deregulating bank's
deregulating finance he ensured that
derivative securities would be traded
without any kind of supervision he
deregulated radio and telecoms and he
basically put an end to the federal
welfare system the old AFDC system one
of the things that he did that most
people don't know about is that in 1997
Clinton had a series of secret meetings
with Newt Gingrich and they arrived at a
plan to privatize Social Security people
the meetings were secret at the time but
it's since come out it's a it's a known
thing people have written books about it
it's well documented Gingrich now talks
about it but they had this series of
meetings they came up with a a plan for
privatizing Social Security what how
they would roll it out how they would
introduce the policy Gingrich had the
votes Clinton would sign it and Clinton
actually took the first step in their
proposed plan in his State of the Union
speech in 1998 he said he said oh geez
what was it we need to I almost said we
need to end welfare the welfare as we
know it but that's not what it was he
said we have to a shoot now I can't
remember what his exact words were but
you know what happened to all this he
had this great plan for privatizing it
the very next day after his State of the
Union speech the Monica Lewinsky scandal
right and that put an end to that we can
thank her for basically saving the
Social Security says though I'm quite
serious I think I think Monica Lewinsky
is a hero now Bill Clinton you know
interesting guy he had this strategy as
a candidate when he was running for the
presidency had this strategy where he
would go out of his way to insult or
distance himself from some traditional
Democratic constituency like organized
labor or minorities and thus I assure
the public that he was his own man the
most famous example also happened here
in Chicago it was a Jesse Jackson you
remember they called this
the sister souljah moment when clinton
sort arranged or contrived to insult
jackson to his face before the cameras
of the nation and the democrats or of
the clinton school had this kind of way
of rationalizing this you know they
could insult these people with impunity
they thought because remember this
phrase they had nowhere else to go right
remember that now what's interesting
about clinton is that this campaign
tactic eventually became a full-blown
philosophy of governance for this guy
right body-slamming the people who got
you elected and the classic example here
is the North American Free Trade
Agreement or NAFTA
and you remember what this was about
George Bush senior had negotiated it
with Canada and Mexico but he couldn't
get it through Congress because Congress
at the time was controlled by old-school
Democrats but Bill Clinton could do it
and he brought in your current Mayor
Rahm Emanuel who was his write his point
man on getting NAFTA Pat come on now
folks and I remember this very vividly
because I was living here in Chicago at
the time and I would watch this on I
live down on 48th Street and we'll talk
about that another time but I would
watch the debates over this on my stupid
little TV set in that in that house any
of so NAFTA it's a fascinating story if
you think about it when Clinton got
NAFTA past Clinton rammed it through
Congress
he wasn't merely insulting his friends
in organized labor who opposed NAFTA he
was conniving in their ruin okay he was
assisting in the destruction of their
economic power
he wasn't just insulting them he was
materially injuring them he was right
doing his part to undermine his own
party's greatest ally to ensure that
management would always in forever now
have the upper hand over workers
whenever they tried to organize or went
out and complain about something
basically anything because now
management can always say well we're
going to move the plant to Mexico
always make that threat now and this is
well known they do it all the time
and sometimes they even follow through
on it but it bypassing NAFTA Clinton
made the problems of working people
materially worse okay now this NAFTA is
interesting for a lot of reasons and one
of them is that it was as close to a
straight-up class issue as we ever see
in this country NAFTA was and it gives
you when you look at the debate over
NAFTA back in those days in 92 93 it
gives you an idea about what our modern
Democrats stand for and what groups they
mean to please and like I say I remember
very vividly watching these debates on
my TV set down in Hyde Park and the
debate came down you know it was very
obvious who was on which side
professionals and the rich were in favor
of NAFTA working people were opposed to
it people with graduate degrees were
always very impressed to learn that 283
economists had signed a statement
talking about how NAFTA would boost
employment creation and overall economic
growth and that sort of thing now
ironically of paradoxically or whatever
you want to whatever adverb you want to
use the predictions of the unlettered
blue-collar workers who opposed NAFTA
turned out to be far closer to what
eventually happened than did the rosy
scenario those 283 economists and the
Rhodes Scholar who sat in the Oval
Office President Clinton but no matter
Bill Clinton's admirers the New
Democrats they called themselves
regarded this as his finest hour
they used this phrase all the time this
was his this was a particularly brave
act this was his greatest moment as a
president and you can find a version of
this viewpoint in an admiring 1996
biography of Bill Clinton by the British
journalist Martin Walker who said that
yes Clinton had done a few things wrong
but he these things were this is a quote
from the book in the end balanced and
even outweighed by his part
finally sinking the untenable old
consensus of the New Deal and the
crafting of a new one that's why this
guy liked him that's why he admired Bill
Clinton because he killed the New Deal
consensus okay so this new consensus
that he talks about this new consensus
that came up to replace that old one
with who were the heroes of this new
consensus well the same democratic
thinkers of that period that I've been
describing you know who were always
saying that the party needed to abandon
workers in the New Deal they had the
answer who should the Democratic Party
serve what should Democrats embrace well
it was obvious right the emerging
post-industrial economy and the people
that the Democratic Party needed to
identify with were the winners in this
new economic order we were entering the
highly educated professionals who
populated our innovative knowledge
industries right lawyers doctors the
math PhDs who write the derivative
securities the biochemists who make the
prescription drugs now if you can
remember back to the 1950s you'll you
will recall that professionals were once
very solid Republicans back in those
days but by the time of Bill Clinton
they had entirely shifted in today they
are one of the most solidly Democratic
groups in the country and that's who the
Democrats are today they are the party
of the highly educated professional
class they have other constituencies of
course minorities women and the young
for example these are the pieces of what
they like to call the coalition of the
ascendant but when you read Democratic
literature you quickly realize that
professionals are the ones who come
first these are the ones whose
technocratic outlook always prevails in
democratic party arguments it's there
it's professionals tastes and manners
that are celebrated by liberal
newspapers and it's their particular way
of regarding the world that is taken for
granted by liberals as being objectively
and obviously true so what I'm saying is
that professionals dominate liberal
and the Democratic Party in the same way
that Ivy Leaguers dominate the Obama
cabinet a Democrats so a big part of
listen liberal is me reading a lot of
Democratic Party literature magazine
statements this kind of thing and they
have all of these wonderful flattering
phrases these terms of endearment for
their favorite demographic they call
these high achieving professionals the
wired workers who will inherit the
future they call them a learning class
that truly gets the power of Education I
love that one by the way a learning
class so some people are in the working
class and other people are in the
learning class right isn't that great
the one that you're going to that you're
going to know they are a creative class
that naturally rebels against fakeness
and conformity they're an innovation
class that just can't stop coming up
with awesome new stuff right and
Democratic leaders themselves are of
course drawn almost exclusively from the
ranks of this very same demographic
group that I'm talking about it's not a
coincidence that both Bill Clinton and
Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton for
that matter we're all of them plucked
from obscurity by prestigious
universities you look at Bill Clinton's
life story it's sort of this classic
tale who the Democrats are nowadays he's
a kid in Hot Springs Arkansas goes to
Georgetown University and the doors of
the world swing open for him he becomes
a Rhodes Scholar and he goes to Yale Law
School you know that's who he is
and Barack Obama's life story is very
similar as so many of Democratic leaders
are the time that they spend at really
fancy schools is what defines them as
individuals and you look at at their
cabinet choices either Clinton or Obama
it's always the same kind of people
these successful professionals from a
very limited number of institutions
successful professionals whose wealth
has been established by their
achievements in college or graduate
school so think about what I'm saying
here they have the the party has
developed a theory
history where this group is like the
winners right they are the hero the
heroes of history standing at the at the
Telos at the endpoint of all of the
great dialectics of history the
professional class they are the winners
they are also the parties number one
constituency and they're the demographic
group from which all the parties leaders
are drawn okay what I'm describing here
is a basically a complete shift of
allegiance from the traditional working
and middle class to this other group to
professionals and this I think is what
explains so much of what is frustrating
about our modern-day Democrats for
example this is what explains the
problem that I started off with the sort
of vexing problem of Obama and the banks
why was it that the Obama team failed to
do what obviously needed to be done with
the Wall Street banks why did they
declare that Wall Street executives were
going to be held to a different legal
standard than ordinary criminals and
they did declare this the guy who said
it had to resign immediately but he did
say it it did come out why did Team
Obama choose Wall Street over average
people again and again and again and
again every time there was a choice to
be made they always went that direction
why because for the achievement
conscious people who fill the Obama
administration investment bankers are
more than friends these guys are
classmates these guys are peers I mean
the two groups Administration Investment
Banking these two groups are essentially
the same people go back and forth
through the revolving door in DC there
is no difference Democrats you know in
the leadership code leadership clique
they look at Wall Street they see it's
filled with these people of subtle Minds
sophisticated jargon and extraordinary
innovativeness you know making up
derivative securities plucking wealth
out of thin air it's the most amazing
thing in the world this is exactly the
kind of creative industry and creative
individuals that Democratic parties
tells us we must honor and respect right
they're making these financial
instruments that are so admirably
complex by the way I have a anecdote
here I have a friend who's a bank
regulator back in the 80s he's old
school bank regulator he had a hand in
prosecuting a whole bunch of SNL
executives back in those days and he was
telling me that when he used to do this
stuff that he and his fellow bank
regulators when they would look at a
bank and they'd see undue complexity
like guys you know doing all sorts of
crit you know what I mean undue
complexity they would say ah red flag
fraud you know zero in under they're up
to something
let's have a look at that let's take a
closer look at that but with the Obama
team when they see complexity it's the
opposite you know what they say when
they see that they like
sophistication right they love that
stuff
it's like financial rocket science as an
Obama administration official once said
and by the way when he said that it was
as part of a explanation for why they
hadn't prosecuted these guys its
financial rocket science nobody can
understand it and it's the same for Big
Pharma right so innovative you can't
import generic pharmaceuticals no you
have to protect these innovative
companies and folks mega dittos for
Silicon Valley right an industry that
can do virtually no wrong in democratic
eyes I mean these guys are so lovable so
professional so creative that for them
enforcement of our country's antitrust
laws has basically been suspended for
this one industry when Hillary Clinton
was Secretary of State she used to
travel the world calling for something
she called Internet freedom by which she
meant that access to certain Silicon
Valley servers you know Facebook Google
that sort of thing access to these
certain servers was a basic human right
okay so what does a party of the
professional class believe in well the
most important item on the list is of
course meritocracy the conviction that
the successful deserved their success
and that the people on top are up there
because they are the best this is the
first commandment of the professional
managerial class
everyone gets what they deserve and what
they deserve is defined by how they did
in school okay
now folks this is wrong in about a
hundred different ways but the only way
that I'm going to talk about here today
is that this is not a good way to take
on the problem of inequality indeed this
is not a doctrine from mitigating
inequality this is a way of
rationalizing inequality right you know
you get what you deserve
and you maybe you just did you know too
bad that you're struggling out there
maybe you didn't go to the right school
maybe you didn't study the right subject
maybe you didn't get a college degree
maybe you've got the wrong college
degree it's always a way of pushing it
back on to the individual inequality
isn't the fault of the system it's the
fault of you and what I'm getting at
here the larger point is this there is
no solidarity in a meritocracy it is the
exact opposite idea
now professional leaders of the
professional class like these guys in
the administration and these guys on
Wall Street show this enormous respect
for one another but they have almost
zero sympathy for the less fortunate
members of their own disciplines right
if you think about the white-collar
workplace when somebody gets fired in
the white-collar workplace their
colleagues don't rally around them and
protest or go on strike or something
they never do that there is no
solidarity or I could tell you my own
story about I went and got a PhD I'm a
member of this class and when I got out
of the ph.d program it turned out well
there were no more tenure track jobs in
the humanities any longer we all had to
work as adjuncts it's the it's the
humanities are falling apart folks it's
been happening been going on for twenty
years now and what's the response of the
I mean there still are people at the top
of these disciplines and have a lot of
power
how much sympathy do you think they feel
for the adjuncts who've been screwed
that's right folks it is a big big goose
egg there that life doesn't shower its
blessings on people who can't make the
grade is not a shock or an injustice in
this system it's the way things ought to
be okay so
the story that I tell in listen liberal
as you can see is a happy and inspiring
one this is the gradual coming together
think about it though it kind of is in
this 19th century way this is the coming
together of money and merit of success
and righteousness this is the marriage
of Finance with political virtue and
virtue and righteousness are what being
a liberal is all about these days but in
another sense the transformation of the
Democratic Party has been a disaster
think about it this way left parties all
over the world were founded about a
hundred years ago to advance the
fortunes of working people that's why
these parties exist go look at the cross
of gold speech right but our left party
here in America one of our two Monopoly
parties lest we forget our Left Party in
America has chosen over the last 30
years to turn its back on these people's
concerns and make itself instead into
the Tribune of the enlightened
professional class a creative class that
makes these awesome innovative things
like derivative securities and
smartphone apps and the working people
that the party used to care about
Democrats figured had nowhere else to go
in the famous formula from the Clinton
days folks they have found somewhere
else to go by abandoning these people
Democrats have made inevitable but the
economic desolation that you see in vast
parts of the Midwest as well as a
populist backlash against liberalism
that has been building slowly for
decades twelve years ago I wrote about
it and what it looked like in my home
state of Kansas and today it is
everywhere the backlash is here it's all
over the country now swarming up out of
the D industrialized zones screaming
it's bizarre and ugly slogans
and just think about the political
choice that that leaves us with this
year on the one hand angry right-wing
intolerance and on the other inequality
forever folks there has got to be a
different way thank you very much
[Applause]
all right
so we're going to take questions and
we're going to tell acog Oh anecdotes so
just a few points my name is Gary
Leavitt le a vit D from Skokie you said
your TV when said you watched was stupid
well I don't know since we're on TV
maybe it wasn't a smart TV but this is
important this TV Charlie taught my
expressions this is the way I talk just
ignore it
that means I really loved that TV grew
like it drew Weston and George Lake off
have written books to a political mind
the political brain which are very
interesting Charles cross I marina book
about columns was he said he wanted he
said know thyself is very overrated I
think you have to think about the
problems of underprivileged
neighborhoods contributed to crime and
religious violence bleeding - well
obviously after fifty years of therapy
I've come to realize they generally
don't know what they're doing and though
you wouldn't believe it be nice to kids
and they think you're a pedophile why
isn't there why isn't there a nobel
prize in psychology and could you
nominate me to win it oh you got it man
okay I love Chicago
hi mr. Frank it's a pleasure to meet you
enjoy what's the matter with Kansas one
question do you think you might be too
hyper critical in regards to the
Democrats and do you think the
Democratic Party might be rolling back
to its New Deal roots you mentioned for
example the issue of privatization of
Social Security I didn't even hear that
he did Clinton and Gingrich had
conspired with five activists yeah time
they can now Hillary Clinton so she's
going to defend Social Security and
expand it under Obama we've gotten Obama
care they raised a top rate for taxes we
did get dodd-frank at least with some
things yeah do you think it's rolling
back I think uh well there are signs of
hope let's put it that way and I
shouldn't the one mistake is that I
think I mean the one thing that I will
you know say about what you just
described they aren't all the same so
Hillary is different than Bill and
Barack Obama is different than both of
them
and Barack Obama here's a man whose
heart is I think clearly in the right
place and yet you know when you look at
his great big three achievements as
president with the stimulus dodd-frank
and Obamacare and all of these are
flawed in exactly the sort of the way
that I've been describing that you know
always reaching out for complexity when
it's totally unnecessary
dodd-frank you mentioned it is twenty
thousand pages long and it's getting
longer by the minute there's this it's
because they're they they they left it
up to basically two lobbyists and
regulators to you know to write the
thing and they're in DC right now
working on all the loopholes and
exceptions and you know on and on and I
just goes and goes and goes it would
have been so much simpler to just you
know to choose the kind of elegant 1930s
style solution it's like now we're
breaking this industry into there it
goes yeah it would have been so much
simpler but no they had to reach for
this this well it we can and the envy
the Obamacare has the same flaw so it's
not that I think that Obama is a you
know is a Bill Clinton kind of figure I
think he's a different kind of president
but then as soon as I say that you know
I pick up the newspaper and here he is
pushing for the trans-pacific
partnership you know he thinks he's
going to get that done in his last year
in office and it's like why why do it
you know it so every time I start to
think you know maybe I've been a little
too hard on the Democrats they do
something like that yeah
is there another it's just yes first of
all thank you for being here one of the
selling points at the time with NAFTA
was the success I'll put that in quotes
of the US Canada free trade agreement
which happened in 1989 and it seems like
even now in 2016 when the orange one
attacks NAFTA it's more about Mexico
than Canada so I guess one of the things
we're missing in this discussion is and
also the flaw with the TPP is when you
have countries of a certain economic
strata competing with countries of a
lower economic strata and being dragged
down to the bottom instead of raising
all of it so I guess the question in the
discussion I'm curious to get your
perspective on this if the US Canada
free
trade agreement had just happened for
like these last 30 years or so in Mexico
had not been involved would that have
been a better example of free trade or
can free trade only exists between
countries because US and Canada are
somewhat in economic strata so I guess
I'm that's been missing for the debate
no with that with that that deal bid in
Canada I mean if the Oh Canada hates it
for many many reasons
oh absolutely my Canadian friends I mean
oh yeah he brought down the government
there the voters they were like no way
I've it was it Mulrooney yes
yeah that's it went down because we went
all the way down to two seats and he had
passed the baton to Kim Campbell and
she's even lost her so went from a
majority to two seats oh how bad it was
yeah that's I mean it kind of closed me
but a well-deserved mr. Miller blue room
but uh so what people often don't
realize about NAFTA and by the way NAFTA
is not the most harmful of the trade
agreements it was it was the first one
that we really fought about we had a big
public debate over it and so it's always
remembered as the as the moment when
this stuff happened but it wasn't it
didn't by itself you know there were
many many many free trade deals after
that one but it was the big one and what
people often don't realize when they
think about NAFTA is that tariffs with
Mexico we're already very low and
tariffs with a lot of other countries
are we're very very low these deals are
like NAFTA is something like 2000 pages
long if you wanted to do something that
was like free trade with Mexico it would
be a one page you know if not what NAFTA
did NAFTA is about securing the property
rights of investors in Mexico it removes
the Mexican government's power to
nationalize industries so that's that's
what it did it made it so that you could
move you could build a factory in the
zone along the border and take advantage
of all of their you know the labor laws
and that sort of their laws is the wrong
word but they're the you know the
economic situation there and and you're
in no danger of the government coming in
and nationalizing are doing any other
things that governments used to do
you're in no danger of that happening so
that's what NAFTA changed but tariffs
were already low you know all of these
deals like you look at the trans-pacific
partnership
you know some of it is about about
lowering tariffs but a lot of it is
about like protecting big pharma there
you know these and another thing I
always I always have to remind people
about trade agreements you know we talk
about globalization all the time
everybody in DC talks about
globalization as though they know what
it means right they know what
globalization means it means you know
these people are winners these people
are losers and that's just that's God
doing that globe that's the globe you
know that is this other almighty power
that we can't even question is doing
that to us but in fact trade deals which
are how globalization happens are
written by humans and they're written by
a specific category of humans they're
written by lobbyists and they're written
to protect certain industries and defend
certain classes of people and to ruin
other groups I learned this when I was
writing listen liberal economist friend
of mine who talks about this constantly
he was around for the NAFTA debate you
know he talked about he knows the
subject inside out and he loves to talk
about how you could write a trade deal
to ruin any class or category of
Americans and to protect any other
category or class of Americans
professionals always think you know
globalization you know it's making me
rich you know it's not because the deals
are written that way just because I'm so
awesome you know you could write a trade
deal that would import enormous numbers
of doctors and lawyers into this country
ensure that they are qualified and you
would draw even you would basically
drive down the wages in those
professions like way way way down it
would be great for people who consume
medicine and legal services you do the
same thing to education you can do the
same thing to any industry if you wanted
or any category but that's never on the
table it's always it's always you and me
that gets screwed right sorry I need to
shut up I'm being told I need to shut up
one more quick question okay try and
make it quick first thanks very much for
saying what you said I think if anything
you've been moderate and cautious and
it's what needs to be out there well no
one ever says that but I am I try to be
responsible I try to have a reason for
saying
well I was in the I was working in a
Northwest Indiana steel mill when NAFTA
went down I guess I'm one of those
people and we've been having this
conversation for a long time about how
we have two parties that both represent
Wall Street's they are both devoted to
Wall Street when it first went down our
union leadership told oh there is no way
we are supporting Clinton in 96 he has
betrayed us yeah but guess what yes but
and by the end it came to well we have
to come to grips with this thing of
having two parties of Wall Street but
not this year this year it is too
dangerous this year you know we could
get Bob Dole for president and then
people would just be permanently
replaced when they were going on strike
so I guess Bernie Sanders is one of the
names that sort of hovers unspoken under
this conversation and I feel like the
rebellion that he launched is being told
the same thing oh you have wonderful
ideas and we're it's so inspiring we're
so grateful to you but you can't do it
this year because this year is too
dangerous yeah and so I know yeah we're
every year is too dangerous
when is going to be okay can I just
we're out of time but let me just throw
in one comment about that I feel one of
the things that that just breaks my
heart about poor about organized labor
is they work their butts off for the
Democrats every four years maybe they
turn over their treasury to these guys
they get out on the streets and they
they go to the polls and they do phone
banks and they drive people to the polls
and they work work work work work and
then it's like and then they go to say
President Obama and they say here's our
one issue right ESCA right employee Free
Choice Act right Obama's like yeah okay
and it dies and then it's like okay
sorry guys you didn't get your what and
this happens every four years why it's
because the fear of the Republicans is
greater than is their anger at
constantly being betrayed by the
Democrats and they are constantly
betrayed by the Democrats of the
Democrats like you've got nowhere else
to go and we all know it and folks that
is a situation that all of us are in and
ultimately this has this comes back to
the two-party system which is failing us
okay let's end there alright everyone
thank you very much for attending this
presentation Thomas Frank will be
signing his new book listing liberal
right outside the back you can provide
any feedback to us at our website thank
you very much
yeah
when you're watching book TVs live
coverage of the Chicago Tribune printers
roll it fast that was author Thomas
Frank talking about his most recent book
listen liberal the festival will
continue in about ten minutes with
Marcia Clark this is book TV on c-span
too